on va tirer ou là c'est moi c'est pas
disproportionnée c'est ma part je
connais un gars et jouer sa place
maintenant mon frère j'ai tous les
chroniqueurs et si je suis dans la lah
je ne sais pas quelle est la question
je vais tire au sort tu retires au sort
a bataillé l'éboulement innocente avoir
aidé à ig metall a eu 9 centimes et
naïve innocente et oui les mecs qui se
sent assez morale à donner dans la poule
a c'est vous aurez pour vous montrer
alors je prends tu sois là pour montrer
avoir gardé sa l'a7 et celle qu'il
fallait pas me regarder
cyril hanouna à la nage c'est pas moi
mars voilà donc j'ai savoie c'est sûr
que c'est pas moi dassier pour
jean-michel berges envie celle d'hier
maillot pas donc si ce n'est pas la
réponse
ban en b mais c'est pas une question de
culture générale
[Applaudissements]
question laquelle personne ne me répond
c'est la question qui pue c'est une
tannée quoi allez c'est parti
afficher la quête show qui fait placer
les chroniqueurs dû plus jouer au moins
doué au lit
selon votre intuition ou votes à vendre
bah ça tombe bien sûr vont très vite à
les louer aux moins doués barre à gauche
mais je me limite où tu tombes mois le
plus doué après je mettrais jimmy sina
com ainsi qu'à son jeu en trois
carrières ex aequo avec benjamin et que
les sommes non
oui oui que les hommes a que des hommes
pareils peut vraiment je t'ai pas dire
non raymond souvent et maxime bien
évidemment on classerait bien souvent
peu plus tout ça me déçoit pas